après à le regarder dit la vérité qui
les regarde et je suis tombé dessus a
déjà regardé un film porno dit la vérité
vincent clerc oui c'est un groupe assez
c'était quoi disparu elle a disparu du
dernier métro n'a jamais regardé de
films pornos moitié en ruine on vous
avait déjà vu julien ou bien sûr tout
seul ou accompagné
si c'est pas une ma mère pour
l'embrasser
benjamin cassany ça m'est arrivé ça mais
pas aimé samedi dernier avec votre femme
non merci on faire vriller dit la vérité
ça me dit non pas samedi dernier je le
savais je dis ça vous savez que le
ticket canal+ repose bien sûr sur le
foot mais aussi ils ont lancé le porno
plus fameux tournoi par mois alors là
moi ça a été un carton
donc c'est une recette qui fonctionne
dans les pornos oui parce que vous avez
vu jouer dans un film érotique un genre
calimity de calamity schneck
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est épuisant si j'ose dire et la nuit
d'une harde de canal pour le coup il n'y
avait que des scènes de pénétration
c'est une grande longueur pendant deux
heures et demie si ça vient et on a
envie de savoir
franchement agathe et kelly benhaim on
sait qu'elle a regardé la un film et au
porno sait jamais si la dernière main à
sa médiane ne veut pas s'alarmer à gaza
gardait ce que tu as tourné jargal dit
la vérité c'est important ben j'aurais
préféré parler du cas benzema non merci
donc à aider leurs gardes oui ça m'est
arrivé quand j'ai pas la date en tête
mais ça m'est arrivé oui mais pas noté
sur une petite alma n'a jamais non
jamais la vie par contre un film
érotique en découdre dans le salon wii
ça peut le faire en découdre avec leur
déco accord avec les parents la famille
x toiture soit en famille autour du fait
de la fin quand tu joues bien tu
souffles a fait gaffe d'un ont peu bougé
[Rires]